good morning everybody
and welcome to mid suffolk district
council development control b
third of february today my name is kathy
guthrie and i'm the chairman today
now first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements please ensure that
microphones are muted when you're not
speaking
that you do not interrupt the other
speaker members are all reminded also
reminded not to use messaging chat
function during the meeting
unless it's to report a pecuniary or
non-pecuniary interest or to notify the
chair that you wish to make a proposal
members are reminded they should not
have alternative communication
commute can't speak sorry communication
lines open
i.e other teams chats and that if you
are contacted by a third party
during an application you should bring
this to the legal advisor's attention
but if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions
by myself please await your turn will
not be using the hands up function
except for declarations of interest site
visits
requests for declarations of lobbying
and questions for clarity
we will be using the electronic voting
for this meeting if you're experiencing
poor connection issues in the first
instance
please turn off your camera if this does
not work please turn off all incoming
video
these options are under the three dots
on the main information bar
i would like to remind everyone present
in this meeting it will be broadcast
live to the internet
and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential items or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consented to being recorded
by the council and the possible use of
those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
now just for fun my screen is frozen
i do apologize that's better
my apologies introductions
there's indy prey our legal advisor
robin
robert carmichael our governance officer
the area planning manager
john payton g and the ward members
councillor rachel eben and councillor
keith welland
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence
and substitution
thank you this morning we have apologies
from councillor carsten and no
substitutions
thank you for that
do you wish to take a roll call now
uh i can do chair if that would be
appropriate uh just to make sure that
the public know who's present as well
please
yes of course yeah so if members could
please respond when i call out their
name so counselor peter gould
present councillor kathy guthrie yes
present
councillor barry humphries present
council andrew mellen
present councillor mike norris
council andrew stringer president and
councillor roland ward boys
president thank you chair we are all
here
thank you very much to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members now
robert if there's any hands up can you
just help me here
i i've got councillor stringer thank you
uh yes chair i'm the county councillor
for the sunny village of hawley and
there's highways suffolk county council
advice that's pivotal to this
application
thank you
declarations of lobbying
there are none declarations of personal
site visits
no confirmation of the minutes of the
meeting held on the 25th of november
are there any points regarding accuracy
of the minutes
and councillor um robert carmichael did
you want to speak or
sorry have i got yes no you're the um
that's right
if i could just come in on that point
and just point out the two points that
were made um
there's two two amendments one of them
made at the last meeting
um so members are asked to note that the
minor amendments to the minutes from the
previous
meeting on points 30.4 sorry 30.14
noting that the ward member spoke
against the application and the
amendment to 30.24
as requested at the last meeting and
these have been confirmed by the legal
officer and planning officer who i
consulted
thank you chair thank you for that so
councillor stringer you have a
an issue there please yes so so are we
looking at the amendment
because this isn't correct 30.24 is
incorrect
it needs to have the word as removed
uh the the the the
the motion was not voted on because i
withdrew my
my proposal because we hadn't voted on
it i withdrew my proposal it's the other
way around
but we need to remove the word as to
make it factually correct
can i have the legal and robert make a
comment please
[Applause]
thank you chair um yes that's absolutely
fine if members if
councillors want to make that amendment
as a factual change then that's
absolutely fine
fine thank you very much so with that
amendment is everything all right there
for everybody thank you so
we move on so can i have a proposal and
a second to please
cheer there's another hand up yeah i
can't see hands up sorry i'm reliant on
on the officer
who's the other hand um
chair it's me councillor andy mellon
here oh councillor melanie
yeah um i did raise a point at the um at
the previous time when we considered
these minutes and and obviously there's
been
some emails and and some advice being
given since then
i would like to um ask that um
a point from the debate is recorded
which is
um i would like to suggest this wording
can i just stop you there counselor
melon
we're not adding any points to the
minutes at this point
as advised by emily ewell who's sitting
listening to this
conversation as well uh that's fine [ __ ]
but i will be unable to vote for the
minutes then
that's fine thank you
so can i have a proposer and a seconder
please
councillor humphreys i'm sure more than
happy to propose
approval and do i have a second to
please
councillor gould
so robert can you conduct the vote
please yes thank you chair um
so just to note members um with this
will
um i haven't changed the wording yet so
i've just got to
quickly change the wording with to say
as the amendment as before by councillor
stringer
with the corrections sorry put forth by
councillor stringer so if
i will be one second chair just to
change that so that is correct
for four members and
did you want to read out that other
point that you had um
available for this matter so that
members are clear on what they're voting
on and how please
uh do you mean the electronic voting
count chair sorry
yes yes so if members um go to
the modern.gov app and go to the plus
sign in the top right hand corner
the and click on the attendance
voting tab that'll bring up the list the
point that we will vote on will be
turning blue in just a moment i've just
got to put in the extra wording
regarding the correction
and now the vote should be open
apologies for the delay chair
council humphreys whilst that is
happening could i ask for your vote
verbally please
yes four thank you counselor
thank you chair so with councillor
humphreys vote that is three
four three against and one abstention so
charities your casting vote
i will vote for it thank you
i've lost my notes again
sorry i think it's much easier to have
this printed off
sorry about this
so we now move on to
minutes of the meeting held on the 6th
of january
and again the points of accuracy of the
minutes please
can i have a proposer and a seconder
and robert can you see any hands up
because i'm losing everything on here
yes i believe mine is possibly um
not working properly but i guess you
councillor humphries and councillor
stringer if that's
yes that's what i can see madam chair
yeah so councillor humphreys please
um mom chair sorry my hand wasn't up um
it's councilman melon i believe oh thank
you pardon cancer melon
yes i'm happy to propose these minutes
as an accurate record
thank you very much happy 2nd chair
thank you
councillor stringer can you go to the
vote on that one please
yes thank you chair so in the same place
if members please go to the modern.gov
app
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner
where members will be able to click on
voting and attendance and then go to the
bar that is highlighted light blue
councillor humphreys can i please take
your vote
yes four
thank you chair that is six votes and
one abstention six of those four and one
abstention
thank you
can we um
i'm sorry i'm getting all sorts of
things on my computer
[Music]
is there something with with with the
computers that's um
if i may come in chair at this point i
have noticed that for some reason
on my screen for teams i just have a
very
appreciative uh picture of you but
nobody else
because the settings of everybody else
seems to have disappeared
and i can't so i can't see any hands i
can only see
yourself yes i have the same yeah i
don't know
if the settings of the meeting been
altered robert i don't know ah hello
this has just changed
so there's no it's gone now that's fine
it's put on here you're no longer
spotlighted what does that mean who's
done that
i think that's what the issue was yeah
yeah so if i can explain that yeah i
think it's possibly my colleague
um who is live streaming to um
make it uh make it so that um the full
screen was yourself when you were taking
that part of the meeting but we're
taking that off now i think it was to
try and aid in
showing that but apologies if that
caused other concerns the other problems
we weren't aware of so
well i was sitting here with my mouth
open and i'm sorry i'd lost everything
all a bit odd okay right so we've done
the minutes and we're now
on to uh item seven do you concur with
that robert
yes chair yeah so to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme
another received chair now the schedule
of uh planning applications before we
begin
um i can confirm that item 8a was
withdrawn by officers with my consent
after the publication of the agenda so
that officers can receive further
information to aid members
in determining the application that
could not be received prior to this
meeting
um and all the relevant people have been
notified prior to today
mr payment g do you have any points to
add to this
no chair not really but i you know there
are some legal definitions that we just
needed to take account of as well
so um on that basis it would just be
unfair to bring it and then have to come
back again
which is easier to uh to deal with it
thank you yeah
thank you for that so we now move on to
the application i'm sorry there's been a
bit of a delay to get there 8b
um dc 2003 900 fish pons way hawley
stone market
and i will invite the case officer john
payton g to introduce this for us please
thank you very much
thank you can i just confirm that you
can see that and full screen
as the starting of the presentation yeah
thank you very much right so this is a
planning application for the
construction of driveway parking area
following the removal of a retaining
wall and repositioning of bullards
this is at number 17 fish ponds way
hawley
so we are essentially in the village of
hawley here and this is the site
just here and
um so what we have is fishpond's way
coming along which is one of the main
roads
into the core of the village and this is
number
17 that sits on a slightly higher piece
of land
than the road itself there is a kind of
embankment running along this point
just to show the constraints this is
outside of the conservation area this is
the conservation area that runs
on the opposite side of the road we have
a listed building that's just up the
road as well but given the distance
and the landscaping and to a degree the
height difference
um you don't really see or are affected
by the
the setting of the listed building isn't
really affected uh by this actual site
itself
the purple we put that on purposely on
this occasion to show
that um mid-suffolk district council and
landowner
and we need to be very clear that
separate from mid-suffolk as local
planning authority
uh uh essentially the land or colored
purple
and that includes um the surrounding
land to the site and the site itself
and that is the reason the actual item
is here before members
as it is owned by the council all
council loan property
developments have to come through
planning committee
on this further plan this is number 17
just to the top of your slide and we
have
a essentially a driveway and footwear
to the front so the driveway at the
moment comes up to
this property here and then it reverts
into a
footpath that continues we have a foot
way
going along at the side of the property
as well
now these are not public rights of way
they are
used for the public but they're not
dedicated public rights away that the
county would control
they are simply footpaths and driveways
as part of the estate
so the proposal is to redevelop the
front garden
now this is the area of the front garden
at the moment laid out to lawn
the actual you change of lawn to
gravel or what have you uh doesn't
actually need planning permission that
is a permitted development
provided that drainage is on site and
the removal of the wall itself at the
front also doesn't need permission
um it's the access being formed
that needs the permission um and that is
the
proposal before us the three other
properties
uh to the south currently have access to
the front
driveway i'll show you more about that
in a moment
so just to detail the use of the garden
would be changed
into essentially two parking spaces
it's a very simple proposal uh not
uncommon
and we also have the bollards that are
essentially just
here at the moment being relocated
further up uh this road
so that it allows access for cars to
come along
the drive and access the the garden and
and park within the garden area
um we have those since uh the report
noticed
that in your recommendation the
relocation of the bollards isn't secured
by condition
so i would like to take the opportunity
to add that to our recommendation
that the repositioning of the bollards
is secured and implemented as shown here
but also
on looking at this again we realized
that this footpath
unusually has no uh bollards
or restrictive gait uh to
either prevent cyclists but using it or
having to get off their bikes to get
around
but also to sort of warn the pedestrian
user that you're coming to the end
of that particular part of the footpath
and then so as part of the
recommendation of
securing these bullard's schema
bullard's to be agreed
we would like to expand that to ensure
that a
beloved or similar scheme is also agreed
at the end of this footpath and i would
like to add that to the recommendation
by officers there is
this is on a hill so it is considered to
be a
a useful requirement to have something
here because when you have
children and pedestrians running down
this hill you know they may spill out
now they do currently spill out
uh unrestricted uh in respect of the
neighbouring property
and that neighboring property has
parking at the front and essentially
they reverse out
so in a way having something here as a
sort of
warning that you're coming to the end of
that footpath would be a general benefit
in respect of the existing situation as
well
but of course we have no record of any
concerns
or accidents known that has been drawn
to our attention
on the current situation
so just to show you what we're talking
about uh here is the
current front garden this is the wall to
be removed and this is the area to be
used for the parking
and these are the bollards to be
relocated further
up and this is the driveway to be
essentially extended
to enable access just as it has done as
you can see
the car just there for the neighboring
property
and just put that into context this is
the neighboring property
with the castle in the driveway there
and actually looking up towards the side
this is number 17.
and just about any context finally so we
have the passageway the footpath coming
down
from the other part of the estate this
is the site
that we're looking at and this is the
driveway that essentially
at the moment stops here because of
those bollards
and just to extend that round to get
into this next property is the proposal
before members
so the proposal is to take a couple of
cars
away from on street parking by very
slightly extend for private drive
and when i say private drive it's the
land owned by mid suffolk district
council
to join up with this site and the
recommendation is one of approval
i will also just finally add um that in
respect of
any consent from mid-suffolk as
landowner that is a separate matter
between those parties and not for
planning committee
the local planning authority are not
involved or aware of any discussion
between mid-suffolk and the parties
involved
but a certificate to notify the owner
within the planning application
has been correctly served and has been
notified to mid-south
district council as lone as land over
just to clarify that
thank you and recommendation is one of
approval
thank you for that john um members do
you have any questions
um for uh mr paytman g and you if you
use the hands up i'll try and find you
any questions for him councillor gould
thank you thank you very much ma'am
chair it's
it's um uh i i would appreciate miss
payton g's
help in reconciling um
what is said in a reported uh paragraph
five about highway safety
and the comments of um the county
council highways
in their consultation response
are they now satisfied because we
provide additional information or is
there some other reason why
those two things can now be reconciled
essentially the highways authority uh
when they first looked at this we're
trying to work out
where's the new access going to go um
and does that involve highway land and
then later on
they discover that obviously this has
nothing to do with highway land
and all of the changes are within
mid-suffolk district councils land
ownership
so essentially they have no objection
because they don't think it
involves land that they are involved
with so
they have they have not objected but you
can take that
in a different way which is they don't
feel they need to really be part of this
discussion or part of this application
so hence why you have the two uh
responses from the highways authority
and it's probably why the wording of
their second response is slightly
strange
in that they are essentially saying it
doesn't involve highway land so we have
no objection
thank you for that is that um sufficient
for you councillor gould
yes thank you madam chair lovely thank
you very much indeed and i think i can
see councillor mellon please
yes thank you chair um mr payment chief
just a quick question um
are there further properties up this
driveway which are sort of
um landlocked and and will we be back
here again
for another application if if we don't
swipe the whole scheme out
um the answer is yes there are further
properties uh further up
that are essentially a landlocked if
i'll just um
to see how many there is there is one
two
i think three uh that would are still
landlocked essentially in terms of you
could continue
the extension of the current driveway
up to meet all three all those further
free properties
so there is a further free but they
unfortunately they're not before us to
determine
okay thank you can i just ask a question
although it shouldn't really make much
difference
um in whose ownership are the properties
uh yes um well this is the
the dilemma the the issue here is the
neighboring property to number 17 which
would make that number
15 is privately owned
and then the further two beyond that are
council owned
right okay so we can have something in
debate on that one and thank you
councilmellon for bringing that up
because i'm sure we can bring that up as
a debate point shortly if that's all
right with you
councilman oh yes sorry i can care
yeah right now just before i go to the
ward members are there any other
committee members that wish to have any
further questions
of the planning officer councillor boys
please
yeah um yes uh just just a point i'm not
sure whether
it's correct to describe this as
landlocked uh
looking at the aerial photograph it's
got extensive uh
black garden which would allow access
from uh
eve beaufort way i believe
can i come back on that because i can
demonstrate that's not the case
um can i just bring the plant back out
bear with me
um back to that
can you see the constraints plan um yeah
just put it back up
okay so just so anything in purple
is uh owned by the council and uh so the
white so
just going back to the earlier question
that white is a privately owned property
which is the next one along from the
site
and then you have two council owned
properties beyond so
in terms of landlocked those other three
have currently got no
uh direct access for parking within
their own site
in terms of the back uh road eve
belmont eve i forgot the name sorry uh
you have a further three houses
around that point so the passageway
to get to the back garden of this site
is just a simple passageway
and if i go back to
that you can't get a car down down there
in order to get into the back garden of
the site
uh because you've got other properties
immediately behind it
uh before you get to the road does that
help uh sort of but if you if you look
at the aerial photograph
um is this a question council warboys
because we can bring this all into
debate
no i was just trying to clarify a point
there may yeah in fact
no access but i look at it on google
maps i mean cars are in fact
driving into the uh neighbouring
property
along that what is your question
sorry it's just i just i was just trying
to clarify
whether it was whether it was correct or
not to describe it as landlocked that's
all
yeah good point yeah i see i certainly
see what you mean there is
um there is
parking going on there and therefore
they seem to have got through
the side of the property um if i go
back to the official map essentially
they are going through
the purple land which is council owned
and going around the front garden
of that property there in order to get
to the drive
i don't know how official that is shall
we shall we use that in debate because i
think that's a very very very valid
point and we can bring
back um mr paytman g uh council of war
boys do you think that would be a good
way of dealing with it
yes um because you brought up a very
valid point there thank you for that
um and then i saw i think councillor
eben was next as ward member but can i
just confirm there are no further
committee members wanting questions
right councillor ebern please um
thank you very much chair i have a
question for the officer if i may
um given that the access from this
property will go on to
a a footway and it's not a driveway it's
a footway
given the access will go into a footway
that mid suffolk owns and is the
landowner
what's the consultation process because
obviously if an access goes into the
highway then we consult with
county council highways but if the
access goes on onto a footway that mid
suffolk owns
could you advise what the consultation
process is for that so that we can
determine the risk and so forth
thank you very much and thank you chair
there is none they are informed notified
uh the landowner in terms of being
informed by the certificate b
that served on the landowner if they
have got any
as landowner any preference to say
anything they needed to come back as
part of the general consultation of the
application which is 21 days
for all parties gosh so there's no
assessment of risk at
all then no because ultimately they
would still need they would still need
permission from the land owner in this
case it's mid-south district council
that's a separate form of
consent that the applicant would need to
achieve so they wouldn't be able to go
without that anyway thank you very much
thank you for your question and um
counselor
your question please
thank you chair um could i just clarify
who is responsible for the maintenance
of the path and the access that's
parallel to the road
and the bollards whether they're the old
ones or the new ones
and the footpath and and the
um treatment whatever is provided
whether it be a barrier at the end of
the footpath
um it is the responsible for is the
responsibility for everything that's
there now and everything that will be
there in the future
down to the landowner who is the
district council
and in terms of the the um
materials and finishing
is that something which would need to
have the
district council housing's agreement too
essentially yes to all of those the
council
is the owner of the land and so i would
assume unless they've subcontracted in
some way that they are
maintaining everything that they own as
shown on that constraints plan
and in terms they would obviously need
to the applicant would see separate
consent to be able to access
across that land and the repositioning
of the bollards the materials
for the the uh the driveway at that
point would all need to be
consented to by the landowner which is
suffolk district council
thank you um just moving on on that
point
um in some cases
planning permission is granted but other
constraints restricted
in its operation so with um
the ward members questions just earlier
if mid-suffolk district council would
need permission for all these other
issues if planning permission were
granted today
is it one of those cases where it sort
of sits in no man's land until those
permissions are given
and councillor eben asked if there was a
process
and you advise there is no process how
does that work
so in terms of planning dealing with the
planning application there was no
formal process of working with
mid-suffolk
to resolve any of these issues because
they are a third party as far as the
local planning authority is concerned
as far as other consents are required um
just because they get planning
permission doesn't mean they have
automatic right to do what they like
they have to go
that's my point yeah they have to go off
to get consent
um from us as landowner unfortunately
they couldn't even have that by now i
don't know because we tried to keep a
clear wall
between us as the local planning
authority and the council as a landlord
landowner and its own interests in that
regard so therefore
you know we do try to steer very clear
of each other uh to ensure that what was
presented to you
is an unbiased uh application uh
oh yeah it's a bit like highways
authority as well ultimately we can
grant access
to a road a main road which the highways
authority are in control of
but the applicant would always need
consent from the highways authority as a
separate
matter and separate form of consent so
there is a second stage to that
and essentially that's the same here
there was the second stage which is they
would still need consent from the owner
and the owner just happens to be
midsuffi district council in this
in this case
i think we'll use that one in debate as
well um right
okay may i come back to the access the
rear if i may
um i've just pulled up the google
street view and it just helps understand
the access of the back
just very quickly are you okay i'd
quickly share that please do
if anything to help members make a
judgment thank you
so hopefully you should see uh the site
so
if i just come back so this is the the
road at the back which is the
bell right way and if i just come back
round
that is the property number 17. this is
the passageway that runs down
uh to the side of that property and i've
just noticed
this has been put in and
i can't quite get close enough i think
it might be a little bit closer but you
can see
that there is now which isn't shown on
our audience survey plans and i didn't
notice this because
because i wasn't the case officer
originally for this um but there has
been put a gates in there
so there is actually access for this
neighboring property the privately owned
property
they have established their own rear
access um
in order to go across here now i don't
know
if that means that this is private land
or public land
uh still so mid-suffolk land or
privately owned land
because i don't know if maybe the map
hasn't been updated to
allow for for that that's something that
mid suffolk needs to look at and follow
through for
um obviously they put all this wall in
but the other two properties are
landlocked so essentially we have got
one that appears not to be landlocked
but the other further to beyond
are but they've managed to make their
own arrangements just there does that
help
it shows us what's happening thank you
right
so we don't have any public speakers so
i'll ask the ward members to speak and
in true fashion i'm sure i'm going to
ask councillor
ebern to speak first and i'm sure
councillor welum will be happy with that
thank you
thank you very much chair i hope my
colleagues happy happy with that um
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak this morning um
firstly i'm aware that the parish
council has supported this application
but i'm
raising a few issues from the
community's
perspective and firstly can you make
clear that this is a footway along the
front
of the property it's not a driveway and
it runs parallel to the road and there's
a large hedge
between the footway and the road and
the um properties if the
um if you could refer to um
slide five and you might want to put
that on the screen
but the to this to the
north of the properties or effectively
the um
south as you're looking at the at your
picture so
we're talking about number 17 here
so if that's number 17 thank you very
much john and so
further to the south number 23 just in
front of number 23 is a square
and that is the parking area off the
road
the green bit at the far bottom right
corner there is the parking area that
serves
23 25 through to 33.
so you come off fish pawns away and you
park in in that area there
now number sorry can you keep yeah thank
you
then subsequent to that um so number 23
doesn't use that
footweight in terms of taking its car up
the footwear it parks on that
um that square area to the bottom right
hand corner
then number 19 which is the other side
of the
little footpath that runs down the side
of the properties
but that one thank you very much john
that one
they applied for um access
up the footway onto their drive for
disabled purposes they had they
needed disabled access to park at the
front of their house and so that was
granted
um then um so the only two properties at
the moment
who take their cars along the footpath
are numbers
um 19 and obviously number 21 was unable
to because
um the access had been granted to the
house further on
on from them now the footpath that runs
along the side of the properties that
connects fish ponds away to eve balfour
way
and john you should know your
mid-suffolk history that eve balfour was
one of the founders of the soil
association
um and hawley um and had a farm in
hawley green but anyway
so if the footpath runs between eve
balfour way and fishpond's way and it's
a it's bounded by two high brick walls
and it's not particularly attractive but
anyway
um kids and people use it cycle down it
run down it um whatever um to get to the
co-op which should be in the top
left-hand corner of that picture
and the as has been shown on the aerial
photographs
the property um the other side of number
17
drives in across that um parking area
in eve balfour way to access the rear of
their property
and i did raise with the planning
officer who's um
which wasn't john but the the planning
officer who was looking after this case
that why
why wasn't the um parking put at the
rear of the property particularly as mid
suffolk owns
the land there as well and it would
obviously have been an easier
in my mind way to put the parking
because i really
worry that this footway that runs
parallel to
fishpond's way is actually going to
become a new road
because what's to stop then you know
number 17 gets parking there then you
number 15 says they want parking and the
two bungalows at the top it
end um out of your pitch for the top
left they decide they want parking
and then it just becomes a road and so
anybody walking along there is gonna
then
be encountering vehicles as well as
um you know delivery lorries and all
sorts of things
and i'm just very very concerned that
we're turning that little footway
into a road and out of your picture to
the
bottom right is um hails meadow
and lots of kids that's the path they
use to school is coming along that
footpath they have to go across the
parking area
that i described um outside number 23
and that's the only bit of road they
have to cross because then they can just
walk up that foot way
there's a little bit of some mary's and
so on and so forth but it's a nice easy
route
um to school so i am very concerned that
that
is turning into a road and
again just to confirm it's not a
driveway it's a footpath
and that is the um that's it's its
status as it were
um and then i'm pleased that um since
you know i raised my comments that
they've um
it's been decided to put the bollards um
at the bottom of the
footpath that runs between the two brick
walls down the side of the site
um because obviously that will um help
because also there's a couple of gaps in
the hedge and
you know people are prone to running
across that what is the footway
to the hedge in order dentists just to
cross over fish bonds
why if needs be so in short i've got
um three three concerns really firstly
why there was no consideration to
putting this at the back especially
since midsufficon the land
um at the back as per the property
next door secondly the conflict between
um pedestrians and vehicles
and thirdly just the fact that this is
becoming a
road in its own right and i think that
that we need to be very very
careful with that thank you very much
chair i really appreciate being able to
speak this morning thank you
thank you very much indeed and can we
ask if members have questions for the
ward
member please
counselor mellon um
yeah thank you chair um can i just um
clarify the
the the two houses further up i'm not
quite sure what the numbers would be 15
and 13.
have they got access from the other end
is that um sort of off
um station road or whatever it would be
there
num number 15 they they park round the
back
um they're they they're the ones that
you know in that picture it's right to
buy as it were and so they
they take their vehicles through the
back um via eve balfour way
yes and that and then the two bungalows
to the north of that
um which is numbers 11 and 13.
um those those are two bungalows and
they don't have any vehicle access at
all
they just have um pedestrian access
okay so the road to the um north
sorry is that station road or something
else i can't quite that's
mary's avenue yeah um immediately right
past the bungalows we were talking about
um is st
mary's avenue okay so so from
mary's avenue into this um
walkway there's just pedestrian access
yeah so on the corner of
um fishpond's wayne st mary's avenue
which is opposite the listed building
there
um there's a it's quite a high high-ish
bank with hedging around it
and um a grassed area
so there's no did you want me to
i'll just try to assist a little bit
more if you don't mind if i share
i had say google again because i haven't
got photos
of it um if i shared that
so this is mary's uh avenue
and the two bungalows are just beyond
the tree there
and that's the walkway that goes yeah
see their members that's the standard of
the walkway
that runs around there and that gives us
a better view oh did actually hang on
let me just go back one
yeah thank you john that's showing the
hedging that's all around the edges
hedges around the edge
because the boat is running along here
and then that's the footpath that goes
up and then of course
changes as it goes so i'm not sure if
i'm going to be able to see through the
hedge much as i walk along here but you
can just see the bungalows
bungalows there
and then you've got
i think they've blurred out information
as they that first house you can see on
the right of your picture
is number fifth is the next door
we're going up the hill there is a
little uh
steps there but you're right there are
gaps
because they run through the gaps to
them to get to the
and you can just see that's quite good
uh you can see the
the brick quite significant brick uh
structure uh that is the footpath that
connects then to the
footpath and you can see on here you
have the
um access to the property currently next
door
and if we go further up there's another
access
there for that next door neighbor and
you've got then the 23
which is that one on the corner if it
allows me
to come in a bit thank you that's this
is the parking area i was referring to
that's the parking area that i i don't
know if this
our particular site uses this if you can
turn the left very slightly you can just
see
there the um the three number 17
just beyond the um yeah the high hall of
high hall high wall sorry of the
footpath and it just shows you see the
only reason that footpath there was
widened
with uh with tarmac put on the left hand
side is because that
um property got disabled access for
their car
and so beyond that the footpath is just
a footpath it's not
it's not driveway or a road or anything
and this area here
in to the right of the picture is what's
used for for parking for the
um six houses that are around that
um square as it were i will say though
and just to note that there is no
special compensation in terms of
disabled access only
along this point it is open to
anybody's use to get to those properties
it's not specifically restricted in
terms of
for disabled drivers only that's all
thank you for that um any further
questions for councillor ebon please
no andrew thank you andrew okay
councillor mellon um
can we now have councillor wellam please
thank you
thank you chair thank you for the
opportunity to speak
uh clearly it's advantageous for the
residents of number 17 to be able to
park off-road
and to have a clearly defined access
between
the road and yeah via the
by the footpath to the
newly constructed hard standing
the parish council made the point that
the works would tidy up the area
so i think we need to bear that in mind
but
it's essential that there is no hazard
created
either for pedestrians or cyclists as
well as for motorized road users
i note that suffolk county council are
content with the application but that's
because the works
uh are to do with footpath footpaths
there to do with
land that is not public highway but the
devil will be in
the detailed layout and the finer
details may need to be sorted out
as works proceed it may be that there
will be more pedestrians using
the the footpaths when the new houses
are occupied
uh there's a significant number of
houses being built on fishpond's way and
people will
cross over i mean john might be able to
show
the the the plan of where the new houses
are being built
crossing over the road and using that
footwear and also the little gap through
um so it's absolutely essential if this
is approved that
there is treatment at the end of the
the gin or the footpath that comes
through from eve balfour way
to make users of that footpath aware
that there may be vehicles
as they emerge at the end of the
footpath
but there seems to be a safer
alternative and we don't know whether or
not
and i mean it's right this is a this is
the planning committee planning
committee don't know whether or not
um a potential access via the belfaway
has been
discussed with um with housing offices
so it's it's really difficult
um because i can see the advantages
particularly for the residents of the
house of the applicant
but there are there are disadvantages
for other
particularly pedestrians in my view
thank you thank you for that counselor
um do members have any questions for
councillor wallam
no i have um just another couple of
questions for um
uh john payton g if i can indulge myself
on that
um john where did this application come
from
um how did it arise in the first place
um i can i can have a quick look at the
um
the details of the applicant but
ultimately
i would imagine it would i believe it
came from the the the party in the
house itself i'm it's not from
mid-suffolk
if that helps and and is that how
privately owned then
no it's a it's owned by the by my
suffolk
um so both the applicant and the agent
of course that's at the top of your
report are not um in suffolk district
council
um they have served notice on
mid-suffolk district council but as a
i'm assuming tenant um they would then
separately need to go off to
mid-southing district council to get
their
consent for both the works within the
grounds of the
house as well as the access changes
beyond their house that's a separate uh
consent they would have obviously need
to get
uh to agree with the owners of the land
okay that's interesting thank you and um
just following up from councillor
welling's point um i'm sure somebody
raised
uh he and someone else wrote it earlier
um
as clearly pointed out and we can see
it's not a driveway it's currently a
footpath
and should it then be used by vehicles
who would maintain that
and at what standard i can't answer that
though
completely other than the council would
continue to own
and i assume maintain and be responsible
for the road
footpath driveway i'm i'm sorry if my
descriptions of it have
offended i will happily call it a
footpath but it is a footpath
certainly solidly for some length but
part of the length
it's a shared footpath with allowing
cars along it
right so up at the moment the shared
arrangement is up to the current
bollards the point of this application
is for that shared arrangement to
be extended um and just to be clear but
at the moment at the front of the
property
it is certainly just footpath only at
this current time
and just for clarity again so that we
know the applicant and the agent
were not mid-suffolk district council no
they're not
and did they have um pre-planning
application on this i can't see that
it's mentioned
um it says um
no so i will take it from the case
officer who's constructed this report
that that but
certainly haven't had any
pre-application advice okay well sorry
to have
jumped in there so um right
we've had both members speak we've had
questions i now open the matter up for
debate please thank you very much
anybody like to start us off
um oh no wait a minute sorry i'm going
round i do beg you pardon i'm doing
do me things counsellor gould can we go
for you first
sorry nothing for me at this stage thank
you
councillor humphreys
thank you two seconds
manchester thank you um i just gotta
play my buttons two seconds it's playing
up
there we go oh muncher thank you um
we're now in debate yes
yes indeed yeah i'm glad this has come
to planning
um because this is the great thing about
planning committees
um you get to see things and then after
debate and after the questions
it all sort of makes sense because when
i first put the paper up and i read it
i thought oh this is really simple makes
a lot of sense
two vehicles off the road parking on a
household fantastic
and everybody agrees with it that's
wonderful this will go through really
quickly
and then of course we've had debate
we've had questions we have the
explanations by the offices
which have pretty much changed my
opinion of this um
i really do have to sort of concur with
councillor ebert
um and councillor warboys and councillor
mellon on all of their points
and councilor wellam as well actually
this is a footpath and it doesn't matter
that the other bit
is a shared vehicle vehicular access
this element is definitely a footpath
that's the most important thing
and also it's very close to another
footpath that comes through an estate
that people use so you've got to think
accident backwards haven't you
really before you make any decision at
all this is
a crazy proposition i think it's right
next to a footpath it's on a footpath
and we're now going to put vehicles on
it
why and um council ward boys mentioned
the fact that perhaps could be at the
back
and i think it's a fairly good
assumption to be honest with you
but i'm going to come back actually and
ask the the officers
and i'll give you a couple of minutes to
to answer the question really the most
important question
who's paying for this is it mid-suffolk
district council or the applicant
because there's quite a lot of cost
involved
however you skim this including moving
the bollards
and if we are going to move the bollards
going back to council um
mellon's point then surely we need to
move them as far north west along that
footpath
as possible so that if other applicants
come forward in the future
and there's no certain that they won't
then we don't have to move the bollards
another two times
and spend even more taxpayers money so
that's the question
who's paying for it i'm not going to ask
you how much it costs but it'll be a
considerable amount
and then we'll come back to the point of
or what's the point
because actually the parking area that
the cars are parked in currently
is not in my opinion too far from the
property itself
it's a walk and you know what i'd rather
you walk that distance
than put people at risk by changing your
footpath into a driveway
and as councilory burn rightly said it
will be used by delivery drivers and
everything else
even though there's a sign on there that
says no parking people will use that and
it will become a small road
i think for the safety points aside
that we shouldn't approve this and i'm
surprised about the
previous application that changed the
old footpath
into a shared driveway i found that
crazy as well
but but there were reasons for it and i
get that and people made a decision on
what they had in front of them at the
time
but if i was to make a decision on what
i've got in front of me at the time
right now having listened to everybody
and their concerns and i'm surprised
that
nobody's made any comments in the
document they're all yeah no comment
let's move on i find that really
surprising i just don't think i can
support this application
um it really has flipped it on its head
for me and i'm glad it came to the
planning committee
i'm glad that we've had this debate
thank you
thank you councillor humphreys um now we
go to councillor mellon please
um thank you chair um if you drive
through
hawley regularly as i do um
there's a particular spot on the kind of
crest of the
um fishpond's way where if someone parks
um it creates a real hazard and people
often do park there
um and you end up having to try and go
around a vehicle when
uh you can't really see around them um
so that was my
initial sort of reaction to this that
you know if we can get
cars off the road that's going to be a
benefit but
as we've unpacked this and and got got
into the detail
it has become a bit clearer to me um and
i find myself agreeing you know
wholeheartedly with with castle
humphreys
there is perfectly adequate parking
um off the road within a very short
distance of the house um
i mean my initial thought was if this
has been allowed
for properties number 19 and 21 then
there's a kind of fairness issue surely
this house should have it as well but
once i'd heard that it was about
disabled access to the neighboring
property that sort of
clears that up in my mind i i i can't
um really countenance losing
effectively a section of footpath
um to to vehicles and having that
conflict between
vehicles and pedestrians and cyclists um
just for the um the benefit of that one
householder that seems too much of a
trade-off to me
so yeah as things stand at the moment um
i'm not keen on this scheme at all can i
just have a
bit of clarification from the um chief
planning officer
is there a um pedestrian crossing of
fishpond's way planned from the new
uh development opposite which would
connect to this footway
[Music]
um i can't answer for the chief planning
officer but i will
um in i can't answer the question either
i i don't know
i haven't got those plans before me so i
don't know uh the ward member might
know more than i do on that particular
point um
yeah okay i think i'll leave it i need
to
if i may share i can come back at the
end because i think
there's a couple of clarifications of
what we should legally be deciding and
not
legally deciding here so i'll come back
at the end
indeed but um um i don't think it's fair
i can see councillor ebern's hand is up
i don't think it's fair to expect her to
sort out the planning
issues on another thing but if you
happen to know it i'm more than happy
uh for cancer ebon to tell us but um um
i think it's to be noted that mr payment
g didn't um
put this paper together and there are
certainly
gaps appearing and so um you know any
extra information that we can get will
be helpful to members to make their
determination
counsellory bundy did you happen to know
anything about that one i can't remember
i do
i do thank you chair um i i certainly
do know so to the um as you come into
fishpond's way
um from stone market um on the left-hand
side where there is no footpath at all
is is a development um being currently
being built of 65 homes
so um and that's that green space there
and it comes it
it it stretches down onto fishpond's way
just south of the bungalows that are
next to the side
yeah and as part of that site because
there is a footpath on the other side of
the road
there is a level crossing being put in
place so along the
along the frontage of the new
development of houses
the developer is providing a footway
and they are also providing a level
crossing
to cross over the road which is exactly
almost at the bottom of your picture
um so that it connects with the footwear
um that then goes up the right hand side
of fishpond's way which is the footwear
we're currently deciding
so the owners of um the sorry not owners
but the
um householders from the new properties
will all be crossing at that level
crossing and all using that footway
to then take their children to school
which is just at the north of your
picture
off the north of the picture and to go
to the shop which is um
on the left-hand side of the top of your
picture thank you very much chair
yes thank you for that as soon as i saw
that extended bit i recall it but
as you can imagine um the ward members
are the best person's place thank you
for refreshing me um
right so um how did you finish your
debate councilman mellon
uh yeah can i just sorry i apologize for
promoting john patman g
um so we'd like to hear if john can come
back to us shortly and then come back to
that point
are you happy with that yeah yeah that's
fine yeah sorry i got his title wrong
yeah um so counselor can we hear from
you
in or john payton g have you got the
answer to those questions yet or can i
move on to councillor norris
well the question was obviously in
respect to the the development on the
other side
um the earlier questions from
uh council humphreys was in respect of
who pays for this well the answer is we
don't know
um i don't know if it's going to be the
applicant or going to be the landowner
um that's not within our remit to know
that
and of course that could change any time
i don't
know if there's any other further
questions outstanding
okay um i think i can see which way this
one's
um heading with lack of information um
so we move on and it's councillor norris
if you would please
sorry my uh that's all right on a bit of
a goose low this morning
well this has been very enlightening
actually like counselor humphreys when i
first read these papers i thought oh yes
all straightforward no problem but with
the
detail and the the devil as i say
is in the detail and thank you to the uh
ward members for all the additional
information and clarification
they've brought to this um and now
i am really not so sure actually
it is certainly not as straightforward
as i thought
and at the moment i would be inclined i
must admit
actually to not um
go along with any recommendation for
approval
but i'll listen to what the other
members say thank you
thank you for that counselor norris um
may we have counsellor stringer please
uh thank you chair there's been a lot of
titles got wrong today
could i ask that the councillor
humphrey's title's made right on the
titles here because it's doing my head
in
the fact his name is so incorrect excuse
me madam chair i explained when we came
into the meeting
my council laptop is not available
i've got thank you i'm sorry it's just i
don't like it
i think it's disrespectful when people's
names have got wrong sorry
your name is spelled incorrectly on the
title that's okay
but you know i i just don't like that
okay
uh right uh yeah just
again agreeing with councillor humphreys
at the start this looked really easy
i thought we were going to be
conditioning the bollards actually to go
slightly further down the hill
uh so the both sets every house could
access along here
uh in the future if they wished uh and
we we make life a bit easier and we
forward plan
but of course when you then notice that
the uh
footpath that comes in from eve balfour
way
is is is connecting into this with very
high
uh brick wall so the visibility of the
pedestrian
is limited or the child on the scooter
whatever it is
is limited the chance of conflict with a
motor car if we allow this
is quite heightened uh yes i'm not
expecting there to be
you know four cars every two minutes
going up here that's obviously not going
to be the case
but you are actually engineering in what
is
a potentially dangerous situation
so and but where we rely on the
expertise here
is with suffolk county council and the
highways department when they're looking
at planning applications like this
should technically we are told every
time they look at the roads and the
highways
but they also look at the path network
now they've washed their hands of this
to say this isn't a right of way
but this isn't what the county council
said when they recommended approval
of the 70 plus homes that we were
talking about and the pedestrian
crossing further down the road
so the county council is trying to have
it both ways and it can't do that
now i'm happy that this committee can be
the county council uh expertise here in
terms of pedestrian safety
we are allowed to do that but of course
if we do
recommend refusal of this uh which i i
think we should for pedestrian safety
alone
we are doing it without that expertise
from the county council
and we're taking on our own shoulders
i'm perfectly happy to do that
because it's common sense and we should
show the common sense
that the county council has clearly
lacked on this item thank you chair
thank you very much indeed councillor
stringer councillor boys
oh yes i'll leave i've got the wrong
background on i'm afraid
um yes i i think uh
as we said said a few times already that
at the beginning this looked very
straightforward
and um you know for the convenience of
the householder
being able to park his vehicles off the
road uh
and easily accessing into the house
makes sense
um but uh reading through it i was a
little bit confused when i came to the
bit about the ball arts i looked at
google maps just for some
clarification and that's when i noticed
that
the there was possibly an alternative to
parking in
uh in the front of the house
um and that the there appeared to be
access
to the rear of the house which
would make it unnecessary to
um eat away at the footpath and then
zooming out a little bit on google
maps you're aware that there's there's a
quite distinctive
footpath around a long fishpond's
way uh up to saint mary's avenue
uh which is separated from the
a lot of the way from the road and
vehicles by hedgerow and i thought
you know looking back at my own village
melis where you've got
footpath next to a busy road quite a
narrow footpath i thought this is this
is
really quite luxurious and you know
really accessible and attractive for the
users
and uh council mellon used the fine word
guinel
to describe the the footpath from
eve balfour way to fishbond's way
from my understanding it's a northern
word that describes a footpath between
uh build buildings tall narrow buildings
and as
council stringer pointed out coming down
to the end you suddenly come out
into into daylight and um
and at present a footpath uh
adding a risk of motor vehicles going up
and down that footpath
is is an is a is an added risk
so from a very straightforward
application where i was more concerned
about
uh the porous nature of the
cover covering the park in space
i'm now inclined not to not to accept
this
at all and to reject it purely because i
think there's a better solution
that will that will in fact protect the
footpath
thank you councillor boys um and then i
speak last
um so um i i'm not going to repeat
everything everybody
said um other than yes on the face of it
it just looked pretty straightforward
but what i would like to point out is
that with clear and concise information
from the ward members
it really gives us as a committee a good
overview
of what's on the ground so i'm very
grateful to them
i'm also grateful to all the questions
um because we've drawn it out
on this one because i do think sadly the
um
report was a bit lacking in in fulsome
information
and i too don't agree with this
application either
so um i see councillor stringer you have
your hand up
please may i have your comments yeah i
i just want to come back on something
that counselor warboy said
he he did say that he felt he couldn't
spot it because there was an alternative
solution
we don't actually know the legalities of
the path
and the access at the rear so i wouldn't
want to rely on the fact there's an
alternative solution
i would just suggest that this solution
is dangerous
i think that's a very fair point and
should anybody propose a refusal
it is on what's before us not what we
might like
um so um if anybody would like to go
round a second time with hands up please
i'm quite happy
councillor humphreys
i'm sure thank you um i'm just coming
back really on
um mr payne mcgee's point about the the
cost of it
although i do get your point i think
it's still quite important because if
it's taxpayers money it's moving to
bollards
resurfacing the surface of this footpath
and something else then that that is a
consideration i think because
um i just think it is but i do get your
point
um are we able to propose at this time
i thought that's why yes yes well we're
up to um
what members would like now thank you
thank you uh having listened to
everybody's debate
um i think we're favoring towards
refusal um
the reason i would like to propose
refusal is purely on the grounds of
safety
and the um removal technically of a
footpath into a shared driveway which i
don't think is acceptable
especially as people have pointed out
the the use of that actual footpath
currently and in the future and i do use
that regularly when i go running
so so i understand it fully um so
therefore i'd like to recommend refutal
on the grounds of
safety thank you very much for that
um do do i have a seconder
sorry i'd be very pleased to uh to to
second for the reasons that
councillor humphreys just given and and
just record my thanks to
uh councillor ebon for actually uh
you know throwing light uh on on this
issue and helping us all to understand
it better
indeed thank you for that councillor
gould um
councillor stringer before i come to you
i'm going to ask the planning officer
um if he
can formulate something on the basis of
what we've told him so far
yes thank you um i've been listening
obviously to the debate
and ultimately i there's a fine line
between what is
planning considerations and what is the
planning merits of the case before us
versus other matters that other
authorities may need to deal with
but equally are not perhaps not as
robust if i can put it that way if we
were to use those
uh matters for reasons for refusal now
i'm going to open my thoughts to you a
little bit here because
i when i listen to the debate what we're
talking about is the
increasing chance of conflict between uh
pedestrians especially those coming from
um the road at the back uh
resulting in a pedestrian safety matter
that's that's a clear planning issue
that you are relating directly to
the change that would occur if this
application were to be
approved so there is a reason for
refusal
i suggest i also picking up on
from my point of view what is a good
defensible position
um we do have three properties already
that have access
along this drive and we have um footpath
when we have no
record of any conflict whatsoever we
have no record of concern
um but and i appreciate that the reasons
that one of them was uh gained access
was due to
uh disability but of course that is a
market
well that is a house that could have
anybody else in it so the the the
requirement of that house
could be removed tomorrow and that isn't
required because of disabled access but
it would still have the same vehicular
access
um so ultimately there was no
restrictions that i could say there was
a difference between this site
and that site in planning terms but
i would suggest and this was picked up
upon in that in the debate
that we do have more recent developments
that are approved
not least on the opposite side of the
road which is quite a significant
development in size
which will as demonstrated has a
pedestrian flow
likely to increase along this footpath
to get to the center of hawley
and i think that is a material change
since the three properties
and their access were considered
previously that wasn't on the table then
it is the material consideration now
so i would suggest that you know given
the recent
local developments that have been
approved in our material at this time
that the increase of pedestrian use
along this front footpath will increase
and therefore further vehicle access
beyond those that have already been
approved
could lead to a further pedestrian
conflict which is considered to be
unacceptable
on the basis of those issues
i suggest policies t10 h16
gp1 and paragraph especially of the
mppf127
would be applicable in this case
i would advise against consideration
of a better alternative might be at the
back
um on the basis that we again we as like
it has suggested we don't actually know
if that alternative is available but it
is also not presented to us
for consideration um
so i am you know we have to judge the
harm of the proposal before us
um i don't know if there was a
consideration on the character of the
area
uh effectively what you have is a
pedestrian character
that you are eroding and if you are
looking at that
there might be some merit to consider
the harm in terms of the the character
but of course
that gets picked up with the same
policies of h16 gp1 and
the mppf in any event if you need to say
this is also going to
further erode the character of the
locality if you needed to add that
so there's quite a lot there mainly so
far i've heard the
safety issue and i would suggest to to
the members that you have both the
safety
issue of the immediate footpath but you
also have
the consideration that there will be
increased pedestrian use
and i think a slightly different two
elements there that can be put forward
as a refusal if you wish to consider
character erosion
as well that that is a a particular
point you may wish to debate further
thank you
uh thank you for that john um before i
come to councillor stringer can i just
go to the proposer and seconder
um with those issues which are really
quite clear
um and i must admit when um john brought
up about the
proposed increase in pedestrians i think
that's very valid because it is
it's got permission and that will happen
um
no doubt so the proposer councillor
humphreys are you happy with the
t10 h16 gp1 um don't forget everybody
has the opportunity to talk to the
motion but as a proposer are you happy
with those
uh conditions um and uh do you want to
add anything
by way of verbal in character and harm
because they are included in those uh
those three points there what do you
think i'm i'm sure yeah
the actual proposal was based on safety
i didn't mention the
the rear axis or any other proposal so i
know you did safety
and i did mention the fact that it'd be
the current
uh use of that footpath and the
increased future
use of that footpath um i'd just like to
go back on one point if i could
um when we look at precedence they've
been set in the past
it is slightly different to the previous
applications we're looking at the
application today
and the previous applications didn't
have the additional
conflict with the footpath coming from
the estate that would then cross the
path of the vehicles coming out the
proposed property
so there is a slight difference um so uh
based on what mr potentially said i
remain uh based on safety for refusal
and why not add uh harm to character
yeah
but mainly on safety councillor gould
are you happy with
with those policies t10 h16 gp1 can be
yeah for me the
the fundamental issue uh remains
uh safety there but i'm happy with uh
as to support what uh councillor
humphrey
has said thank you thank you councillor
gould and sorry you've had a long wait
there um
anybody wishing to speak to the motion
and counsellor stringer has your hand up
unless it's an old one
no no i have my hand up chair thank you
very much normally
the guidance is if we we're going to
disagree with the officer recommendation
we should come up with policy reasons as
to why
uh i i have a few to to consider
uh the mppf under 102c
uh mentions about uh walking and cycling
infrastructure needs to be improved as
part of any development
uh also the hawley neighborhood plan uh
hau
10 policy says that
uh where are we here includes measures
and facilities that encourage
walking and cycling wherever possible
hau
15 let me just find that policy as i
scroll through
says uh new housing business development
shall take every available opportunity
to
improve connections from the development
to existing network of piles and bridal
ways in the parish
this network will be protected and i
think there's an element here where this
this network is not being protected by
allowing this development
uh i hope that helps chair and
um councillor humphreys i think the hou
15 is the protected bid um
i don't know about the other one i don't
know whether you want to add that or not
i'm chair thank you i think uh mr
payment g
actually came up with the parts of the
mppf that were going to be
added to the refusal from my memory
and i get the point from counselor
stringer more than happy to add in the
uh the local neighborhood plan
articles as well it supports it supports
the argument
thank you for that um john can you add
those bits in for
um us please and does anyone else wish
to speak to the motion while we're
just waiting for john to um pop those
things in and then the
officer can go for no further questions
no that's good
thank you very much so i think that's um
where we are at and if robert can
get some words of
chair if you could give us five minutes
because i'm gonna have to quickly type
this up i've written it down on a bit of
paper at the moment because i've just
been trying to work it all out and
generally have started from scratch on
this one so
do you want to just suspend the meeting
for five minutes give me five minutes at
least put some words together very
quickly then i can email that over to
uh rob for him to enter into the system
for members to look at and vote on
so if members just want five minutes and
um robert if you can just
suspend the meeting for five minutes and
then we can come back with a proposal
thank you
foreign
so robert would you like to um or one of
you like to read out the the proposal i
think robert
um for us to vote on please thank you
yes yeah that's absolutely fine
so um this will appear in montgomery
members want to read along at the same
time it will be under the vote so
the proposal is um from this as
sent to me by mr payment g the
application dc 2009
zero three nine hundred be refused for
the following reasons the development if
approved would result in the increased
chance of conflict with pedestrians from
eve balfour
way resulting in reduced pedestrian
safety
furthermore given recent local
developments approved in the area the
pedestrian use of the footpath
network shall increase significantly and
further vehicular access would lead to
increased risk
to pedestrian conflict at this location
moreover the changes to the front
footpath would erode the character
and amenity of the area on this basis
the proposal would be contrary to local
plan t10
h16 gp1 and neighborhood plan policy hau
10 and hau15 and the
nppf especially paragraphs 102 and 127.
thank you councillor humphreys are you
happy with that yes thank you chair
yeah and councillor gould
yes thank you chair right can we go to
the vote please
yes yes so if members could please go to
their modern.gov app
and go to the plus in the top right hand
corner
and click attendance and voting and
scroll down to the light
blue line that should now appear for
this vote
council humphreys can i please take your
vote
for refusal thank you councillor
thank you chair he's just saving so
thank you confirm that has been carried
unanimously by members
well thank you very much indeed everyone
and thank you for all the input
uh from everyone present um
do we have any site inspections robert
no jeff
in that case then i now formally close
the meeting and thank everyone for their
attendance thank you very much